hello
oh
thank you and good afternoon everyone
and welcome to the audit and corporate
governance scrutiny committee
so item one apologies for absence please
and just apologize from council road
chair
thank you any other apologies
can't we move to item two decorations of
interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuny interest
and or other interest not already on
their register of interests in any item
on the agenda
and withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
from three minutes of the last meeting
held on the second of december 2020 they
have been circulated so can we have a
proposal please that they are a true and
accurate record
yes chair proposes
thank you council shipment all in favour
thank you otherwise we want to add a
majority there thank you that is carried
so item four then we move to a
presentation from all in close
our treasury advisors so we're over to
you please
thank you very much hopefully you can
see our um hopefully everybody can see
the slides um just to confirm um
how long are you expecting the um the
presentation to go on for today
um we thought three hours no i'm joking
um
i don't 15 minutes
15 20 minutes um i think and i'm sure
there will be questions so um
i think if that's right with the
committee
yeah okay that that's that's going to be
very very quick then so we're going to
have to um
we're going to have to get crossing so
um okay so um
just a bit of background basically we we
are your treasury management advisors um
so
we we're called arning close we've been
uh your advisors
uh for a number of years now um we
basically uh advise you on all treasury
based matters so everything from
accounting to uh your investment policy
to
whence time you're borrowing and whether
you need to borrow uh
externally at all so we uh sometimes i'm
sure
uh at some point you'll be receiving
your treasury management strategy and
your treasury
um and also your capital strategy to uh
to
scrutinize and also uh full council
you'll be looking to vote on those as
well and pass those
um and so a lot of those it's all it's
all to do with
the um with the uh authorities
investments and debt so um just
moving very very quickly so well what is
treasury management well the charter
institute of public financial
accountancy
recipient have a definition and that is
it's the management of the
organization's investments in cash flows
its banking money market and capital
transactions the effective controls are
the risks associated with these
activities
and the pursuit of optimum performance
consistent with those risks
which is a very very wordy way of saying
it's
managing your money your cash um
obviously
you understand that these things have a
relationship with the budget
but this is your this is managing the
physical cash so
the expenditure the banking making sure
that you can make
payments when you need to when you've
got cash on hand
being able to invest that cash and when
you've got when you need to
when you're when you're when you need to
borrow money that you're able to borrow
it
so i'm just going to skip very quickly
so
most of you will be experienced
counselors and will be aware and we'll
have the questions of well
where are why do we need to borrow and
why do we need to why do we have cash to
invest
every year we have to balance budget and
perhaps there'll be a little bit of
money put on putting reserves or a small
amount of money drawn from reserve
so why do we need to why do we have
these investments anyway well
you may have you know grants council
taxes and charges coming in
but there'll be a mismatch between when
those when that expenditure goes out so
those salaries and goods and services
etc
so because of that mismatch that creates
investment balances
that increase your short-term
investments if
over a number of years you build up
reserves whether that's earmarked for
some purpose or or cash flood size for a
rainy day
that will also increase your investments
in the longer term any investments
that you have are all generated
from either cash flow i.e working
capital
or by your reserves equally you're
borrowing
you may have to borrow short term to
manage
short-term liquidity needs in the year
but your only
the only thing that drives your
long-term borrowing
should be your capital programme i.e you
know capital expenditure
investments in fixed assets in long-term
on
on assets that provide the authority and
therefore
the local area with benefits open for
more than a year and in statute
the only reason you can borrow is for
long-term assets
um very very quickly you have an
extremely broad range of powers you can
basically
within the the legislative and the
regulatory framework
in law you can invest or borrow money
for any purpose relevant
um to your to your activities and for
your prudent financial management
and the localism allows you to do
anything that individuals may do so you
have an extremely broad
range of powers however the
mhclg and the secretary of state also
has a wide range of powers and
they are able to set borrowing limits
upon you
uh issue regulations guidance or
directions so
though you have in in statute a very
very
wide range of powers you also do
unfortunately or fortunately
depending on your view have to do what
mhclg tells you
um the only real um inviolate
rule though in local authority treasury
management is
that the local authority itself so you
must set an affordable borrowing limit
and you must stick to it so if you see
the on the of our
local authorities must the first one is
setting an affordable borrowing limit
so that's your authorized limit and
that's something that the whole council
has to pass you can't delegate it down
to anybody else
and then you once you've set it you
can't exceed it
so that is it's nobody unless you are
are put into special measures or unless
you are you know or some other extreme
circumstance
mhclg will not be putting a borrowing
limit on you and they haven't done for
very for many years
it is down to you as councillors to
decide the amount of external debt you
believe
that the authority can safely carry
and that can prudently carry
treasury management this is to be honest
this is relatively self-evident
um i'm not going to spend too much time
on this but capital expenditure so the
thing that drives your borrowing
should be prudent affordable and
sustainable so prudent meaning
uh you know it's it's normal language
really you know that
that you that it should meet service
needs and provide value for money
affordable in that you can you can
afford it with acceptable council tax
levels
and sustainable over the long term your
the other side of the coin of course is
your investments and the
and sit for again uh requires you to put
your priority on security
so making sure you get your money back
from your investments and liquidity
which means you can get your money back
when you need it
and once you've made sure that you
you've managed the risk of security and
liquidity
you're also supposed to try and get
yields so you're the return
that you get from your investments
should be commensurate with the risks
you're taking
but bear in mind that an authority like
yourself that is
trying to make sure that you're being uh
very secure and uh
very liquid returns are gonna be
extremely low in under the current
um under current uh interest rate
um situation so
again quickly what is your role as
elective members as well
um hopefully you've got you've got a
broad um
a broad idea of what the role of the
council is but i think the most
important thing on this slide and if
you're struggling to sleep this evening
i'm sure you can
you can read through these slides in
greater detail but the thing i want you
to
focus on right now is that challenge
where appropriate
um i'm sure i'm sure you're all aware
that interest rates are extremely low
um if jane and her financial
staff were able to be getting you huge
exciting investment returns that is a
reason to
to challenge because your role as
as elected members is not to choose
individual investments your role um
financial investments anyway um or to
try and time specific loans being taken
out
your job is to set the framework in
which
the uh in which the offices work under
and the officers can't break that
framework so if you say we want you to
do these sorts of things they can only
do those sort of things
and the book really stops with you and
so that's why it's so important to
challenge where appropriate
um decisions that have been made
and ensuring that they're being made
within the framework that the wider
council has set
um i think probably a skip pathway is
considering our time constraints and
go straight on to the current your
current plans so
if we look at um the big question
which is is northeast derbyshire going
to be
a borrower or an investor over there
over the next couple of years are you
going to need to borrow money
over the next few years well this looks
like a very complicated slide but
i can promise you it's not this is
basically just a an idea of
what is what is driving your borrowing
and investment decisions
so the first line here is your loan
capital financing requirement
and we basically just put into a model
your current plans
so your cfr is your underlying need to
borrow the best way to think about it is
it's all of the assets that you've
bought in the past
that you're yet to pay for because
you're spreading that cost over time
you've financed those or you funded
those assets in a mixture of external
borrowing
where you've gone to external
organizations in your case mainly
central government
by the public works loan board and
you've also used some cash that you had
on hand you've internally borrowed
which is a good thing it's the safest
and cheapest way of borrowing
is to spend cash rather than going out
and externally borrowing
but most of your most of your external
borrowing is
um historic and it's to do with your
uh your housing it was to do with
housing subsidy reform
where the council went through housing
subsidy reform
and you were required rather than going
from the old subsidy regime we went to
self-financing
and as part of that you were required by
central government to take on
i think it was off the top of my head
you know around 150 million pounds
so so the majority of that is
is housing related debt so if we then
project
forwards and look at and look at the
situation as it is now first
you've got underlying capital
expenditure that you need to
repay of 180 million you've
borrowed from central government or
other local authorities 150 million of
that
and you've spent 33 million pounds of
your own money
to to finance that capital expenditure
and so
once we take into account your reserves
so many you've put aside and
working capital surplus you had at the
end of last year at the end of the last
financial year
around 26 million worth of cash if we
project
forward your plans all else being equal
we can see your capital financial
requirement increasing to 188 million
as you make more capital expenditure and
then
that that amount reducing over time
as you repay that cfr as you take money
out of the budget
in order to repay debt because you have
a statutory requirement to do so
and you can see that starts to fall so
by 2024
debtors started your underlying need to
borrow stuff has fallen
to under 180 million now the impact on
that bottom line
on the situation of the for the council
is that that means all else assuming all
of these plans stay the same which
i can pretty much guarantee they won't
i'm just assuming that you know all of
these plans happen
exactly as you expect them to which i
can also guarantee they won't
um you should have investment of falling
down to 17 million in 2022
and then rising up again to around 23
million in 2024.
as i said these things this is just a
projection this just gives us a good
idea of which way the wind is blowing
they're all subject to change and so if
the council was to change its capital
plans and decide to invest
further in the local area and therefore
invest more
and spend more money and need to borrow
more money or
if the council was to spend some of
those usable reserves
your investments would fall so if your
plans change the projections will change
and that's another important role
um or another important element of the
scrutiny
you're going to be putting on these
plans is well at the moment
the answer to the question does
northeast derbyshire district council
need to borrow the answer is no
but if the plans change and that can
change very quickly so part of the
scrutiny that you need to put
the treasury management under is well if
i've
just looked at this and said well
according to your plans you don't need
to borrow
and then this time next year you see
that their borrowing was taken out
further borrowing was was was taken
it's a fair enough question for you to
scrutinize them to and to ask
well okay i thought we didn't need
borrow why do we suddenly
why do we suddenly why why did we take
that take that borrowing out now it
could be there was a completely
legitimate reason for that
those legitimate reasons are likely to
be our plans changed or
we spent more reserves than or we spent
reserves for
a specific purpose that was agreed by
council now there's
there's clear reasons why that may or
may not happen but it's about making
sure that
the decisions that you're scrutinizing
make sense within the context of the
council
um very very quickly i'm going to hand
over to my colleague paul
and we're just going to talk very
quickly about where we think
interest rates are going to go to um so
at the moment um
because as you're going to be net
investors we're expecting you to be
anyway
in the interest rate environment is
going to have quite a big impact on
your um on your on the returns that you
can expect but
i'm just going to i'm going to pass you
over to my colleague paul for for
okay thanks steven so um yeah this is
our latest uh interest rate
forecasts um the the top left chart
there is our forecast for the official
bank of england
bank rate with our central forecast
being hopefully you can see it there
the um the sort of the thicker red line
uh and as you can see we don't think
that uh bank rate is going to be going
anywhere anytime soon um
you see everyone to be aware of what's
going in the the news the uh the
the effect that the pandemic has had on
um
lockdowns and on the various economies
um around the world so
all central banks have kept
interest rates um ultra ultra low
and we don't think that that's going to
change in the uk um any time soon the
the silver or the gray line there that
you can hopefully see
is the what's called the market implied
line
and uh the market sort of
believes that there's there's an outside
chance of a
negative interest rate we don't think
that that will
will happen uh there's obviously a
chance but it's it's not part of our
our central case we feel that the bank
of england will
um will keep using quantitative eases in
before
it tries to sort of look at any any
negative interest rate environments
they're still 10 basis points that they
may
um that they may cut um but
what you can do at zero that you can't
do it ten basis points
remains to be seen but that's where we
think uh bank rate will
will stay so certainly for any
short-term
borrowing needs um that would be nice
and cheap
unfortunately the flip side is that any
short-term liquidity balances that
the authority will have will be earning
next to zero
as well the other charts here uh five
ten
and twenty year guild yields that use
them for uh
medium and longer term borrowing for the
authority but again you can see
that we're expecting the yields to go up
slightly
from from where they are over the next
the next three or so
years um but not to any
great uh extent meaning that for clients
who have longer-term
borrowing needs who want to take um
longer term
term pwlb funding that there really
isn't the rush to um
to jump in and uh and
um i mean that's our interest rate
forecast dinner
in a nutshell were there any any
questions on on that at all
any questions from anyone
there in case you can't see your screen
i can't see any indications
for questions no thank you
we'll carry on thank you thank you
stephen did you want to do the uh
borrowing options
yeah i mean i am very very again just
looking at time
just to look at sort of the uh
your current portfolio it's as
as we discussed and all of your debt
currently
is taken out from the public works loan
board um
you can see that most of it is fixed
maturity which means
you you know it's like a just a a
straight
bullet loan so you take it out on day
one
and you repay all at the end of the term
um you do have a small amount of eip and
annuity loans
they are um a little bit like a mortgage
or a loan that you may take out as an
individual you take it out on day one
and then you re repay a little bit every
year over time
you can see that the average because
those uh loans are historical
the rates that you're paying on them are
much higher than if you were to take out
uh take up debt today so
a logical question would be well why
don't we repay these loans
and take out cheaper debt that's in
that's available at the moment well
unfortunately
central government doesn't like you
doing that and so there's these
significant premiums
that you would have to pay in order to
get out of these loans and as you can
see
in order to pay 150 million pounds of
maturity loans back
you need to pay an extra 60 on top of
that
so all together you'd you'd really have
to pay about 210 million pounds to repay
150 million which uh doesn't really make
a lot of sense
um so overall um
you've got the you've got the debt you
need the debt so it's best to stick with
it rather than trying to refinance it
in this interest rate environment if
interest rates would change
and those pr those premiums would change
the cost of you to repay that debt will
change and our advice may
may be reconsidered but as things stand
you have quite a long
portfolio you need the money it's
probably best to keep that money
so just looking at um one quite
important element and that is
recently your main lender the public
works loan board has changed its lending
terms
so previously the public works loan
board would lend to you for any purpose
and really wouldn't ask any questions
about about those purposes
um however um recently
well a year well just so about 18 months
ago the pwb announced it was going to
change its policy
and the results of that came through in
november and
now for the public works loan board to
lend to you
any capital expenditure you make has to
fall into one of these
five buckets
so either borrowing that will
allow you to make to undertake service
delivery
borrowing that will allow you to
regenerate the local area um
preventative action which is a bit of a
strange one but it's basically you know
where if you need to
to step in to prevent something from
happening housing which is a big one it
has its own it doesn't come under
regeneration or
service delivery interestingly it has
its own um its own element because
the the um because uh the government
thinks it's so important
and also that they want you to retain
the ability to refinance old debt
what they do not want you to be able to
do is purchase investment assets
primarily
for yield so all of these things can
wash their faces they all can generate
an income
but they can't be from now on you can't
have anything in your capital program
where the where the main reason you're
doing it is to
to generate income for the authority so
if we were to look at um
your the the authority's housing
um housing project some of your housing
projects
do generate an income over over and
above
what they cost but because the main
reason for doing those things
is to generate housing and and to give
housing in
to increase the supply of homes in the
local area and to look at your
and to help and to support your service
delivery of homes in the local area
it's absolutely fine that they create
that they they generate a yield
the only question is do is about assets
that
that are that are designed primarily for
a yield and
some of those things you know things
like um where you're not going to be
you know where you take on land or
buildings that aren't in your local area
or you take on london buildings which
aren't you're not really
you're purchasing it it's not you've not
done anything to regenerate your local
area you've just
bought an office block in your local
area with no real intention of
of doing anything with it you're just
going to hold it indefinitely these are
the sorts of things that
the central government don't want you to
do and the problem is going to be that
if
it's not just they won't lend you to do
those things
they won't lend to you if you're even
doing those things yourselves without
borrowing for them
so it really chokes off your ability to
borrow from the public works loan board
which is still your cheapest form of
long-term borrowing
if you do undertake those so it's again
is your role
as scrutinizing decisions and
understanding decisions that
the authority is making and quite a big
part of that from now on is going to be
understanding well
are any of our um and bear in mind that
your section 151
so in this case um jane will have to
sign off
whether anything is purchasing
investment assets primarily for yields
so
you know she's got a professional
obligation to do that and there's a
requirement for the treasury tip for her
to
sign off your capital program so it'll
be important for
you when you're scrutinizing decisions
to make sure that you
as members when scrutinizing the capital
programme
understand which of these five elements
any project falls into and if it doesn't
and it does fall into purchasing
investment assets primarily for yield
what the plan the authority has to fund
those
investments because it will cut off your
ability to go into the public floating
board
at the moment you don't need to do that
but it will cut it off for a three year
period
so it does reduce your flexibility going
forward so that's a very important thing
that you will be scrutinizing
over the next few years um
are there any questions on on this
because this is obviously quite
important but i am aware of the time
and before we just do a quick bit on
investments i just want to check that
there's nothing uh that anybody would
like to
a bit more detail on on this part
because this is probably the most
important thing you're going to be
scrutinizing over the next couple of
months or years
just to confirm there are no indications
to speak
okay in that case um we'll just move on
to uh move on to investments i think
if we just quickly i think probably um
just quickly look at your um how your
how you how where your performance is
driven and what drives it and then i
think meeting them we can take any any
final question so i'll hand you back
over before
okay thanks steven so this is um an
example of what the
the benchmarking slides that we that we
prepare uh each quarter
um and then presents at the officers
every time we
we meet with them so it just shows um
even though
it's not a perfect comparison and and
obviously
every authorities uh strategies are
slightly different so
you're not always comparing like with
life but it sort of gives um gives a
flavor
for comparisons across the group so it
would be
comparisons with english non-met
districts and then also our entire
client base so um one of the earlier
slides that we
would touch on because of as a time
showed that you're
you're a lot more exposed to money
market funds in terms of your liquidity
balances
many of our our clients which we we like
they're nice
diversified funds compared to something
like banks
um they're still exposed to failing risk
um
we now have where banks were split into
ring fence and non-ring fence banks
after the um
the global financial crisis so um
we there's even though then you've um
you're still exposed to uh financial
risks
um you're you're more diversified in
money market funds which is why we
prefer them compared to
the banks so just in the box here you
can see your comparison um with our the
rest of our client base
um you're slightly above um the average
uh for for bailing but again there's no
real need for
a concern because you are you are
diversified um
one way to um to reduce that would be to
invest more in other local authorities
where we like their
um their credit risk um
liquidity your obviously your your um
portfolio is focused on short-term
liquidity balances rather than
any longer-term investment so um all
good
there um and then just looking at the
the yield down at the
the bottom there and that sort of borne
out in the level of total return
and uh income return that the um that
the authority
would be earning which is next to
nothing i mean as as
stephen and i touched on in the current
interest rate environment that there
really are no
um decent short-term um
investment returns to be to be had it's
it's only when you start looking at
longer-term investments um it's longer
with
local authorities or housing
associations or into longer-term pooled
farms
um that the income returns start to uh
start to pick up but that would
obviously
require a change of strategy from the uh
the authority to
start looking at those um but
that's can of you mr roberts with regard
to um
loans to other authorities yes you've
made reference to that is that something
that arlington is now advocating
in a covid situation when a large number
of local authorities are financially
struggling and we know
quite a few that have either declared a
section 114
notice or they are they are close to
doing that
and is that a wise piece of advice that
we could be doing that's at this current
moment in time
in terms of credit risk i mean that's
something that the credit risk of local
authorities is always something that is
been
uh comfortable with particularly
compared to
um compared to banks and your ability if
you were to lend to another authority if
it was to get into trouble
you're able to accept that money so that
you wouldn't actually lose
that money it may take you some time to
to get it back
but the likelihood of you losing it um
is is very very low whereas if you were
invested in a bank
that would needed a that needed to be
bailed out
there's quite a strong chance that you
would lose some of that
um some of some of your deposit so
we in terms of our general advice for
local authorities we're comfortable with
them
if there is um an authority
croydon when it's under a section 114
we would advise um probably from a
political standpoint to
maybe avoid it um but in terms of
the um the general credit risk
of the local authority sector it remains
something
we do have money invested in croydon and
they've issued section one before
four notices twice now um
so yes i suppose we could say that
they might be good for the money it
might not be now um
it could be now but you're sort of
saying it's better than perhaps
investing with a bank
so both is risky one's not as bad as the
other is that the upshot of it
different risks so one with in terms of
the
um in terms of the local authority the
credit risk will be
will be low the likelihood of them going
going bust whereas
there's a greater likelihood with um
with the bank but maybe um
liquidity risk is is is maybe slightly
higher
should the authority end up in a in a
section one one four position but in
terms of you know i'll be more explicit
than paul
um that yes is the short answer
i mean a local authority you're
protected in
legislation that you will be able to go
to the high court and precept you know
it's in legislation that your your money
is secured on the revenues of the
authority
so even if um croydon was to go
completely bust if
a section 114 notice was to fail there
would be
um you've got a lot of extremely good
protections within legislation
on the other hand with the bank you're
exactly the opposite way around
the the provisions in legislation
actually
disadvantage you and disadvantage you
specifically as a local authority
so i think that if you take credence
actually a great example
now when um when they um
issued their sexual one-on-one notice if
a local authority had
um already lent money to them we've not
advised our clients
not to break any investments or attempt
to break any investments with
with via with with croydon because of
that protection within legislation
the reason that we would probably advise
against croyd
and making well that we do advise
against new loans to croatian currently
is simply because an is another
legislative issue
which is that in legislation once a
section 114 notice
has been agreed uh
an authority can't agree any new
expenditure
which is not for central uh for not for
central
and um services which um are which are
required under statute
so our concern is not that they will not
pay you the money back because
they they can't not pay his money back
basically our worry is that you may be
entering into a contract
which is untested because we don't know
whether interest payments and
obviously you'd want interest interest
to be paid
uh interest payments are allowed under
the under the terms of section 1 and 4
notice that's our main concern
and obviously there is sort of those um
sort of a um
i don't want to say a political but a a
public relations and a
a issue to this as well which you don't
want to be
dragged into but that sort of uh that
sort of video but but i think you you
hit the mail there doing the thing is
without risk
but the risks around local authorities
are significantly lower than a bank
um i think we may have a question uh
chair yeah i've got a couple of
questions i was just about to say thank
you mr kitching for the short answer it
was yes
followed by a very comprehensive answer
um
but i was actually pleased to hear the
response thank you for that
we've got a question is it counter
shipment
yeah it was just something like what
you've just said about it being a statue
about
with our armor is protected has this
ever been tested has someone actually
ever been served with her section 114
noticed
and then another lender have received
their
money back or is this all we think
that's how the system works
like what's the position so i mean
that's a really uh interesting question
in the sense that and
a number of local authorities have
issued section 114 notices
and none of them have ever defaulted so
none of them have ever not paid the
money back
so the sexual and i suppose i take a bit
of a
i don't want to say with you but i take
a bit of unusual view that i think that
section 100 is actually good
because it shows that the the director
of finance is the person who issues it
and says no more spending until we're on
a on an even keel until we can
set a balanced budget it shows that the
the section 151 officer is taking their
their role very seriously and it shows
that the
almost the fact that they've done this
means that they're on the road to
recovery because
somebody's drawn a line in the sun and
said okay we need to fix this
whereas if you're a private company as
long as you don't break the companies
act
you can do whatever you want you can run
your company into the ground if you want
so there's a there's a statutory
protection there so
the there's obviously the answer which
is well no this is never
this has never been tested because no
local authorities ever not paid their
money back even when they've been in a
1 4 situation and he takes a very
extreme example of
northamptonshire which was in such a
uh it was in such a situation that
required it to be
reorganized into new authorities into
you
uh new unitary authorities no no lender
no local authority lender
no lender of any kind uh lost any money
in that either
all right thank you are there any other
questions
on this slide counselor armitage
you're on mute
right we're all right now uh yeah it's
uh this investments with local
authorities
i can't see the point of us investing in
these people
uh you know why can't we spend the money
at home
rather than helping other people out uh
you know there is a risk you mentioned
about
things a lot of theoretical things uh
in your earlier slides like interest
rates
i ran a business once when the base rate
went up to 18
so you know i regard people
speculating on interest rates with a
pinch of salt guilts of horse being safe
of course the safest is gold bullion
uh but did you uh
advise us to invest with uh
croyton and do you actually
check these people in the way that a
bank does
if you borrow money from a bank they
want accounts
one thing in another cash flows budgets
and all the rest of it
on a fairly frequent basis i mean
as an investment people do you
check people as uh what shall i say
as like a bank would
we certainly look and do credit analysis
on the sector as a whole
and we certainly advised um the north
east dublisher
to invest in local authorities so we
look at it on a we look at
local authorities on a sector basis so
we don't but
to sort of be specific on crawling did
we advise you specifically to invest in
croydon
no but that was within our advice so
certainly not trying to pass it off onto
anybody we it was certainly within the
advice that we've given you
did we look at specific um authority did
we do we
look into specific authorities yes we do
do
a certain amount of um of um
of analysis into specific authorities
which is available to you
however we do think that they're all we
all do think they're all good
and we do still accept in the example of
croydon now they've done a section 114
notice
we would still advise you to invest in
any local authority besides freudian at
the moment
we do do analysis and give and sort um
through our what's called our ideal
trade platform which
your officers can go on and see what the
what the rating is before they invest so
we do do
that sort of analysis but we don't do we
don't require
um authorities for what are relatively
short-term loans
in the money markets to provide us with
things like accounts because
they're already published on the
internet and we already have those um or
business plans because they're already
published on the internet like yours are
and we've already got those so we don't
we don't require any
them to send us any information because
all of that is already published by
um by local authorities or by central
government and we do use us
to take our to to build our view
together um
i think when you ask for why are we
lending these money and why can't we
just use our spend the money in
in in the local area well that's a
that's a decision for the counselors but
whilst you've got
money you do need to do something with
it and if we just go back a couple of
slides that we didn't get a chance to
look at
um you know the risk to you just
sticking it in
the bank is is is extremely high to a
local authority much higher than lending
it to another local authority
um you know and it's not specifically
high for you as individuals or for me or
for paul
maybe for paul because obviously it does
affect um very rich people
but um for people normal people like me
also everybody else um
you know the bank legislation has been
changed to designed
to protect individuals so you know these
retail depositors up here
whereas down here shareholders they're
the first people who
will lose money but unfortunately the
next people are local authorities
and other organizations like local
authorities so
i do under i absolutely understand you
know it's a it's a decision for the
council to make
or should we have these balances anyway
shouldn't we be spending the money
but whilst you've got the balances you
need to put them somewhere and i'd be
very
very worried about you you sticking them
all in banks or sticking them all into
individual banks
because the legislation has changed to
be so punitive
to local authorities
thank you thank you council armitage
anybody else in the question on this
slide
nope that's it so can we continue then
please
yeah i mean i'm just looking at the time
i mean the
i think the the thing to look at here is
how do you compare well this is just
looking at um
the amount that you're getting back on
your on your investments compared to the
amount of risk you're taking
and you can see there's just in a
sensible world the people taking
very very low risk would be getting very
low return and the people taking lots of
risks would be getting lots of return
but you can see there's no relationship
here you know there's there's just no
relationship whatsoever between the
amount of risk you take
and the amount of um and the amount of
return you get
where there is a relationship is that
you as paul mentioned before
is the longest
the people who are around the same and
in such a low interest rate environment
the only way that you're able to
get a higher return on your investments
if you choose not to spend them
is to invest out for longer periods now
the reason that a northeast obviously
hasn't
invested out further up to now is
because as you'll be well aware there
has been a change
in in um in the sort of political makeup
of the
of the authority and that's and what
that's led to is
decisions on the capital program
decisions on spending and
whether whether the whether you're going
to still have these investments
and what we don't want you to do and
what the decision was made not to do
is invest money out for a long period of
time and then find that you need it
so that's what we didn't want you to do
we wanted you to have some certainty
around your plans before you started
investing out
for a longer period of time i think
you're starting to get that certainty
now
and starting to get sort of a bit more
of a of a clear idea of what your
capital program is
what your likely drawdown of reserves
are obviously these things are subject
to change and subject to the
subject to the agreement by the
councillors but we
do have a broad idea of which way the
wind is blowing on
on this and that you will have
investment balances
over the next three or four years and so
you can start to make decisions
um where you will invest out for a
longer period of time
um so yeah i think i'm just i'm just
very aware of the time we said uh we
said we said 20 minutes and we're
we've done half an hour so well i
actually have 40 minutes so
um i think probably we have got a few
more slides but it's probably best just
to
to leave it there and give you time for
any more questions that we have or
or i don't know you've obviously got a
you've got other things on the on the
agenda after this
so um i'll come back to the chair at
this point
thank you so if you can just go back to
full screen then i can see everyone
yeah um
[Music]
thank you and then we have got some
questions so council barker please
yeah cheers chair thank you uh
yeah yeah there's a lot there and i know
we've been through it before
and the investments and and stuff uh
i'm still trying to get med ran some of
the figures and and some don't match up
with the report that
i've read through a couple of times it's
you know some of the
the figures that you've just skidded
about how much we've borrowed and how
much we've got left at the end of the
day
but 188 million we seem to have borrowed
most of that's for the hra for to pay
back the uh
what we borrowed to to sort the council
houses out that's fine but we've got 26
million pound
flight in cash at the end uh and it
might be a recurring three and three
through this meeting
uh we've just borrowed a million pound
nearly for
for a project why didn't we use some of
that 26 million pounds
to instead of borrowing it that's that's
one of my questions i suppose
i just if that section one of your
questions
counselor can just bring the section 151
officer in
to answer that bit yeah for me thank you
chair
yes councillor barker it's it's the
process by which we have to demonstrate
the for the treasury management strategy
how we're actually how we're actually
funding a scheme so
although we've said we're borrowing
we're we're not actually externally
borrowing it we'll fall into that
internal borrowing line so we're using
our balances to fund that we're not
actually going out to the market to
borrow anything at the moment
because we're holding all of those
reserves so the term borrowing is
is loose because it means external and
internal borrowing
okay i thought he said public weight
boulder on that report that i read but
i'll try and dig it up it will be
internal borrowing if the reports if
reports different then that's
that'll be my oversight i apologize it
is borrowing but it's internal borrowing
it hasn't
okay thank you
it is borrowing its internal borrowing
though yeah it's
part of that 26 million or 23 million
that it'll be in
24 is that yes that's right yeah okay
that's answered that one
i'll leave it at that at this point
martin we'll come back
hopefully go in with another question
while you've got the floor no no i'm all
right more on the reports that
we'll talk about in a bit thank you are
there any other questions for anyone
i think from my point of view i just
wanted to i think that at some point we
might
as a audit committee might have to have
a little conversation more about the
bank risk
and bail-in and ring fencing information
because
looking at the benchmarking information
that we've had today from all in close
which i thought was extremely helpful
it's clear that
even though you're not particularly
worried it's a little bit higher than
benchmarks authorities and other las in
the country
and and maybe it is worth us looking at
it because we know the precarious
situation of banks and so on
um and particularly the situation that
we're in and maybe just to bring that
risk
down somewhat and perhaps a report on
on bank risk and what else we can do to
mitigate it could be helpful
i hope the committee would agree with
that um
the other one was the investment
strategy i've always talked about this
hundreds of times now um and while we
know it's not particularly a brilliant
time to be
investing in some things i've always
talked about
an investment strategy that has
minimal risk to it but better than no
so risk adverse that we might as well
just be putting money in a shoe box
under our beds
uh and i do feel that as a nordic
committee
we haven't really addressed this and i'm
just saying to section one five one
officer at some point
and perhaps in the working forward plan
of our committee that we do need to
address this
the other thing about the loan maturity
profile it's good to see that beyond
2054
things look a lot more positive so i'm
looking forward to
talking about that when i'm a counselor
in 2054.
any other thank you for that are there
any other comments or
questions from the committee
you want to answer that to section 151
office anything the comments i've just
made
sorry everybody hadn't forgotten my
microphone on yeah happy to address both
of those chair we've um
we've done an awful lot of work to move
our money away from
the banks as stephen and paul will
attest to we were much
more highly geared towards the banks
this time last year as you will recall
so um we are that is something that's
very much on our radar too we want to
move that away
and we are looking to diversify we're
working with them our colleagues all in
close at the moment to start to look at
potential housing association
investments which will have a better
return
and have a longer duration and they're
the type of things that we want to
diversify into so
more than happy to take yes just just
one point on the on on on the bankers
there and the bailing risk it's worth
saying that
because of the the amount that the
authority is holding in
in money market funds even though it
that's exposed to bailing risk
the nature of money market funds it is
you would be spread across sort of 30 or
40 banks
so rather than you just have been
invested in lloyds or santander those
those single name banks that stephen
mentioned
earlier by being in a money market fund
yes you're still exposed
to bailing risk it's spread very very
widely so the chances
of all of those banks getting into uh
into any difficulty is you know it is
minimal so even if there's one the fact
that you're in a diversified fund
um helps to reduce that credit risk so
they're certainly from half space
um and yeah we've been working with jane
to to spread that risk out so there's
certainly no concern from our side that
even though
that bailing number was perhaps are
higher than
the average that doesn't necessarily
mean that you're sort of
you have a super risky portfolio no no
we accept that but 85 percent i will say
still high
and um quite a bit above our benchmark
to neighbours so
um i think it is worth addressing and
thank you for offering to look at that
with the section 151 officer council
shipment
thanks chair and i was just wondering
given the fact that we um
obviously declared a climate emergency
not one bank do we make sure that we
avoid
investing money in fossil fuel industry
et cetera
is that something that we actually make
a point to do it
section one five one off i said you want
to
look at that it so it's not something
that i've particularly
paid attention to because the majority
of the things are within money market
funds but i will certainly have a look
at that for you councillor shipman
let me take that one away i think the
bank of england the bank of england
has certainly tried to sort of push that
there's been a big
push on on um on the larger fund
managers
to um to look at those sorts of things
but less focus on the banks where at the
um
mark carney the old bank of england
governor he's been sort of putting
pressure on
on the banks to look at who they're
lending
to um to more of what's called an esg
focused
environmental social and governance
concerns
for that so pressure is coming on on
that side but it's
honestly the committee has mentioned
before we did talk about ethical fund
management
and you might recall my little quip
about the only ways epics
um so um i think
you know we are mindful of it so um i
think it's important that we do
consider it so um if we could talk about
that at some point maybe have a briefing
about
um ethical fund management at some point
coming to this committee
sorry i mean just to just to jump in i
mean um
i'm sorry my sound went a bit funny i've
had to change microphones but the um
as paul's pointed out you don't have
anything directly into
into um in in in fossil fuels
um however yeah there's the issues that
course pointed out but we we have for
other clients uh
looked at um sort of the uh
we obviously it's not our place to
decide what your ethics are
so we don't we try not to take a view on
what is ethical
however we've we have done for other
clients um
an analysis of investments and how those
investments
uh interact with general esg principles
so that is something that
if we were going to come back um and i'm
aware that i'm sure that the uh the
democratic services people will be
tearing their hair out as i say this
because that your your meetings are very
tightly
uh organized but if you do would would
like us to come back to committee over
the next couple of months we'd be more
than happy to
if you'd like to present something
specifically on banks and something
specifically on esg
if that would be helpful for the
committee and i would be more than happy
to do that and
to discuss with jane how that would be
best presented
um and if that's something else that
you'd you'd like to look at you know
these are things that we've
we've done in the past and are more than
happy to do first northeast derbyshire
i think the committee would welcome that
it gives us more information so
um i think that would be extremely
welcome as i said
and the committee always expect to have
additional reports called for in our
agenda so
um there's always space for another one
uh councillor kerry i'm just conscious
have you got a question that you want to
ask
i'm just conscious that you're not on
screen
not at this stage martin you you could
ask nicola carver if you
if you would please to unblock me video
so i can try and get back on this screen
that's done for you now counselor kerry
thank you thank you well that's it then
for
mr kitching and mr roberts thank you
very much for illuminating us with your
presentation today
and your attendance so you can depart
thank you thank you thank you very much
councillor and thank you very much
councillors
cheers thanks right so item five then
report of internal audit consortium
manager so we're over to jenny for the
business continuity
maintaining financial control report
thank you chair um so the last committee
meeting the committee uh
requested a report on business
continuity specifically in relation to
maintaining financial control
um so hopefully this report provides
members
with some assurance that the council has
got appropriate governance and financial
arrangements in place
to be able to maintain financial control
attached to the reported appendix 1 is a
review that we undertook
of council's compliance with the sit for
financial management code so sifa
published this code in 2019
and the aim of the code is to provide
guidance for good
and sustainable financial management um
it's split into six key principles
which cover leadership accountability
transparency standards assurance and
sustainability
and the code doesn't dictate how you
actually demonstrate those principles
but it gives some
ideas and thoughts to the sort of things
they would expect to be in place
and so we had a look at those and our
review concluded that the council does
demonstrate
good compliance with those areas which
helps to
um demonstrate financial sustainability
um another aspect is that we do review
the council's main financial systems on
a very regular basis
and as you can see from the report all
of those
have received substantial assurance in
recent years
which is a very good indicator that the
controls are in place and they're
running appropriately um external
auditors
have also haven't raised any concerns
and the 1920 accounts
have been signed off uh and a statement
that appropriate
early for money um systems are in place
and lastly appendix ii looks at the
financial areas of the recovery plans
and uh there weren't any uh issues
identified or concerns there
so in conclusion it is a very difficult
financial time for councils and there
are
challenges in place as i'm sure you're
aware
but i think hopefully the report
demonstrates that northeast derby
council
has got effective systems and projects
in place that will help them to cope
with those financial challenges
uh and i'm happy to try and answer any
questions thank you
i've just got one which is with regard
to recommendation two
um which is about um benchmarking
arrangements
why is that down as a low priority when
benchmarking arrangements and a
methodology that actually helps us to
look at how we're performing against
other
benchmarked authorities and so on is
actually a helpful way of
determining what how we're doing
i don't get why that's a low priority um
i think it's because jane and her
section already do undertake some sort
of informal
benchmarking um sit for do have a
financial resilience
um benchmarking but i from what i
understand it didn't really work last
year it
the authorities weren't comparing light
was like
i think they've made some improvements
this year um
whereas i think one of the issues was
different councils call reserves
slightly different things
and the benchmarking that sit for
undertook was kicking out some perhaps
strange results um and i know jane
brought a report to the committee last
meeting i think looking at some
benchmarking
um and that it is something that jane
keeps an eye on so
i'm confident that uh finance
do look at that and we'll continually
look at ways to
benchmark with other councils may then
in response to that i think the fact
that um
the methodology has not been consistent
across authorities over a period of time
it hasn't been while i've been a
councillor and i've been i'm coming up
to 20 years
and the fact that we we still have this
problem because of
the ways that the council deal with
their own budgets or
vocabulary use or whatever would say to
me that we still need to work out a
system and yes last time the last
meeting we did have benchmarking
which was extremely useful and i thought
it was a good way of actually uh
indicating how this council was doing
and it could be something i'm sure
most people will be continuing to talk
about so the fact we've only just
started down this pathway
of benchmarking in the way that i would
hope i i would have
probably asked that the priority was not
low
that it was actually a move to medium
but um
i'm just going to ask the section 151
officer for a comment
i have no objection with that sure if
you if you feel it should be medium
you're absolutely right benchmarking is
only a can opener it's it's always
you're on mute oh i might can you hear
me
i can hear you yes i always got you you
you're muted
yeah yeah i'm i'm operating a two-way
system so i've got
you can see me on my laptop but i'm
talking through the chamber so it's
it's a little bit strange sorry about
that no sorry yeah it is it is um
a benchmarking i always find is a bit of
a can opener so it's a great start point
but then you always have to delve into
the detail because there's just so much
inconsistency otherwise so
so you know more than happy to do do
more of it for the committee if that's
what you'd like us to do i thought it
was quite a useful exercise too last
time chair
let's open that can then it's not an
exact science but at least it's
uh it helps us so we'll move that
priority to medium
please yeah so happy to move the
priority to medium
i mean we do try and look at it from a
risk basis and i guess
it's is there a risk of not undertaking
detailed benchmarking and i guess
we would perhaps argue that there's
other mitigating factors that
um you know the governance arrangements
in place but
but i'll tell you i'll take on board
your point and we'll move that up to a
medium
thank you are there any other comments
or questions
no thank you it's a very comprehensive
report
thank you so we moved to the
recommendation that the report be
noted do we have a proposal for that
please council club
second by council shipment all in favor
thank you that's carried thank you so we
moved to item six then these are reports
that from the head of finance and
resources and section 151 officer
uh 6a money laundering policy refresh
how would you please jamie
thank you chair you've all seen this
policy in the past and it simply is just
a refresh so i'm not proposing to go
into any detail over it because then
it's not the most exciting of reports
it's just basically been updated for
changes in legislation there's no change
to our operations or our policies
whatsoever within it so
i'll take any questions if there are
rather than go through the detail
any comments or questions on the policy
refresh
council shipment can you go through the
the three highlights
really well i'm just saying what
has there been anything neither are we
talking like they've removed the word
birth from a policy and
like what have they done it's it's
literally
we're obligated to refresh them every so
many years so we refresh them so
every so many years and literally that
is the
the extent of the change i'm obligated
to bring it to the committee every three
years i believe so
there is no stream i'll propose that
with you
see that glass of milk has done you the
world of god so a proposal then from
council shipment do we have a second uh
thank you council armitage all in favor
thank you that is carried then item b
treasury
management over to you please jane
thank you chair um you've probably heard
enough of treasury management this
afternoon so again i'm not proposing to
go through these reports in any detail
they are the annual reports that come to
the committee every year prior to going
to council for
approval in february so you will have
the treasury management strategy
that deals with the cash investments and
that's largely what arlen close have
just been talking to you about
you will have the investment strategy
that deals with our investments now
these are what are called
service investments so these these fall
into the category of service delivery
delivery for that that table that
stephen just showed you with
so we can still borrow from the pwlb
steven was right to raise that that is
going to be hugely challenging for
councils going forward especially those
that have got more ambitious plans to
to basically cover off their budget
deficits by doing something a little bit
more creative
and then the final one is a capital
strategy which details our plans
for the capital programme for the coming
years and how we're going to finance
them
so happy to take any questions
councillor barker
count farming miles under all mid papers
i'm lost uh it's just for just for
clarity really yeah i'm not trying to
catch you out at
all jane i'm just i've just read through
some of this on page
60 that table table one
the the middle thing less external
borrowing and it's got the two stars
have you got it can you
it says shows only loans to which the
council is committed and excludes
optional refinancing
what does that mean yeah basically what
that's talking about
it's the loans that we've actually taken
out at the moment so so what that would
mean is when when steven just showed you
that table that showed that the
borrowing drops off after so many years
i think it was 14 years when the big
debt drops off
what we'll probably do with most of that
because it's hra borrowing we're still
going to have the houses
we'll probably refinance that at that
rate so that's what it's talking about
it's talking about us
as moving forward with refinancing and
not
it's talking about what loans we've got
at the moment in simple terms
right we're just a refinancing bit yeah
and i think i'd also got a note on on on
the next page
1.22 liability benchmark
he against alternative strategy and i
just wondered how that
like the event we've talked about
benchmarking how does that
work yeah and this is very much about
comparing our borrowing against if we
did
something different now we're very the
problem with these benchmarking
um statistics are they're very rigid so
they don't allow a lot of room for
for maneuver within them and and we do
very little other than either use our
reserves or borrow so this would be
if you take for example you may want to
do some leasing or something like that
instead
so it will be if you've got an
alternative strategy to your existing
capital strategy which houses borrowing
or using reserves
how would it measure up but because we
haven't really got any alternatives
it's it's very bland and it's just
literally about using our reserves
our working capital which is that cash
that was in that table the 26 million
or tomorrow so it's um these indicators
aren't that user-friendly i have to be
honest we're just required to publish
them
right right and and the other one on on
the borrowing strategy which
you've answered and that and i'll stand
corrected
that it went i've just looked at the
papers that i've paid
it don't say public word longboard it
just says borrowing
so how we're wrong sorry i apologize for
that and we're going to ask
on that question where you know there's
no borrowing but
therefore we we're borrowing it off
ourselves i think it
that's that's that's covered that one i
think that
oh that's more more or less me on i'm
i'm just being pedantic i suppose i'm
working on that one oh no it's right and
thank you apology i look forward to the
letter
the apology in it as well
it's confusing for us it's very very
difficult when we when we make
a decision to put something in the
capital program
we always work on the premise of
borrowing and i use the term borrowing
loosely because it can be internal
borrowing or pwlb
borrowing because what we want to do is
make sure that we're being prudent and
we've got the worst case scenario in
there should we need to borrow in the
future
so that way we're building in the
revenue costs for minimum revenue
provision
interest payback all of that sort of
thing into our decision making so it's
it's a prudent decision really that's
why we do it i just got one more martin
sorry
i've just seen the other notes on 1.59
investment limits i would just i've just
made a note that
uh the council revenue reserves
available to cover investment losses are
forecast to be 17.9 million
uh how does that i don't understand that
where's that 17.9 million 79.9 million
is what we'll expect to put on our
balance sheet at the end of this
financial year so it is a forecast at
this stage but it's not
it's not far out normally so when we
produce our accounts at the end of the
year
and we pull the balance sheet together
we'd expect to have 17.9 million
available
within our investments to be able to
utilize we can't actually physically use
it because it's tied up so it'll be
titled
cetera et cetera but it's pretty much
it's it's equivalent to the 20 million
that arlen close were just talking about
i think they're thinking that's where
we're getting confused because that 17
didn't match up we worry would
say no you're abs you're absolutely
right it doesn't match up our figures
are more up to date
than their figures i think okay
thank you okay thank you my question is
basically around caveats because we're
asked to look at a
suite of strategies going through to
2024
2025 um and we know that of course
there's lots of external
things that may happen that could
influence outcomes for example that
you've got at 1.10
a selection of external influences
that include covid and we don't know how
things will uh will go from here in the
pandemic in the long term
but we've also got in there the the exit
from the eu and what that might look
like
and president biden from today and how
that might
impact on things so um i think there's a
range of things you can't even forecast
and maybe we can't even second guess the
the impact on some of those things as
well as the the ones that we don't know
about
so i think it's difficult to try and um
talk about a strategy going that far
ahead when we've just heard from all in
close that perhaps we need to look at
one or two things
including um the bank risk and bailing
and ring fencing
so how are we going to just amend this
report perhaps to put some caveats in
or slightly amend the report for full
council that includes
some of the things that we might look at
as a result of the advice we've had
today
yeah absolutely chair we can do that we
can it is always very hard to forecast
beyond one year
that's that's why to a large extent when
we do the mtfp we set the budget for one
year
and then the rest is just financial plan
and the treasury strategies are exactly
the same
the only certainty really is in the in
the current year and even then
there are still some uncertainties
within there so so more than happy to
reference that in the
in the council report um if the agenda's
not already gone i'll be looking at
nikki for some guidance on that
yeah i'm hoping it hasn't gone out
because i think we do need to just
slightly amend the treasury strategy in
light of what we've heard today
i've seen your council shipment i'll
just ask nikki to just answer this
um so in regard to the council agenda
it's all prepped to go out it'll be
going out at 9 00 a.m tomorrow morning
you said agenda
do you mean this paper as well yes i
didn't mean that paper what have we
rejected it
um there is a statement at the top of
the report which says that it's subject
to amendments
that will be given verbally at the
meeting right well we could we could um
circulate an amendment and i think
that's what we'll do
council shipment um given that we can't
um
this strategy apparently might this be
the perfect time to emphasize the not
invested
in unethical um
people and organizations in the fossil
fuel industry which is climate
change planet netzero that we've
approved already
because to me this is this this is this
is the document that we're talking about
right
this has to be um something that's
written down for
officers to follow and to make sure that
we're doing it
yeah i think i think we ought to um
amend the rip i know
nick is now going to have a sleepless
night and i hope not um but what we
could do is say that this report
the agenda stays the same the gender
item stays the same
but the report could be forward
forwarded on from um
after the amendments are made so report
to follow
so um when we're amending the report to
put in some additional um considerations
for external influencing for example and
some of the caveats
and some of the all enclosed things for
example the the thing that all in close
talk to us today about
um ethical stance we could reference
the fact that this audit committee is
actually going to receive further
information
to look at strategies with with ethics
included and so on and we can reference
it in this report without going into
detail because we haven't decided it yet
would that be acceptable to you counter
shipment
you sound not so sure all the fact that
i'm asking you is be well
well when would it be decided sorry if i
just missed that in what you were saying
because what we've decided is the um the
ethical paper is going to come back to a
future audit committee
so we this is going out to full council
on the 1st of february
we won't have decided it by then or how
it might look or what sort of
considerations there have been so i
think if we reference it in this report
that goes to full council
the detail will follow because we will
have discussed it at our
next audit committee or one after that i
have a clarify yeah yeah that makes
sense so are we adding like an extra
bullet point on one of these
recommendations that say um the council
will follow ethical
guidance which will be approved at a
later weather yeah
we're going to consider how we invest
ethically and so on and that the audit
committee will be looking at that
nickel
thank you nikki so you get where we're
going with this
i do i'm just talking to uh uh jane or
jessica on the chat just to confirm what
we can do
uh rather than just delay the dispatch
of this item that will will get the
revised report ready uh to go out with
the dispatch excellent
so that's your night ruined so
okay thank you chair
so can i just just clarify what we're
actually amending we're amending the
recommendations
to include a caveat to reflect the
external influences
and the future development of some
ethical um
funding and financing yeah and that we
are going to look at the the bank risk
unveiling
and ring fencing situation
that that's fine thank you chair thank
you
any anything from anybody else i think
if council barker off to you
i've got i'm worried just on the uh uh
we moved off the uh
financial strategy the failure the
capital strategy um
yeah just just one question on that on
on page 78 1.12 asset disposals where
they're talking
with four and a half million pound of
capital receipts in the coming financial
year
that seems a lot just wonder where that
we're coming from
that's that's council housing as you'd
expect
and it's also got some of the um
investment that we're expecting to get
back as capital receipts from
from northwood group oh are we going to
start getting some back from that i hope
so because
the the capital plans relying on it
it just sent a lot to that oh it is
that's his fingers
yeah okay that that that's fine i'll
leave it to that
thank you any other comments questions
if not can we move to recommendations
then at 6.1
another report with the amendments made
please thank you counselorship and you
have a second there thank you council
club
all in favor thank you that is carried
thank you and their medium term
financial plan
thank you chair as you'll all be aware
it's been a huge
challenging budgeting setting budget
setting process this year with the
pandemic we've had a lot of uncertainty
over our own budgets
and we've also had a lot of uncertainty
over the national settlement which we
we actually got on the 17th of december
the good news was that nothing
nothing major was done in the settlement
and it was just a rollover of
last year's settlement which was a
rollover of the previous year's
settlement so we're now in year six of
the four-year settlement from 2015
what it also included was a series of
measures that were targeted specifically
addressing
um issues that the council had been
facing with regards to covet
so it included some some support around
collection fund losses which
as i'm sure you'll appreciate we're
suffering quite significant losses in
income on the
collection fund in relation to council
tax and business rates
and what this process will do is it will
allow us to spread those losses over the
next three years rather than as taking
that hit
all in one year which would ultimately
hit our general funds
there's also some support for councils
where the
um where the tax base in effect whether
your ability to levy council tax and
business rates has been
reduced as a result of the pandemic and
that's happened because of higher
numbers of either council tax support
on the council tax side or appeals on
the business rate side
and it means that we actually can't
collect as much as we would like to so
there's some support being put in place
there as well
the income compensation scheme
philosophies and charges that's
continuing into quarter one of 21.22
which is a huge help for our leisure
services
and we're expecting to get one more
tranche of covid grant
to ease financial pressures into next
year as well the indicative figure is
491
000 that's yet to be confirmed yet
because the settlement is still
provisional at the moment
we're also getting a one-off lower tier
services grant which is
um 205 000 which was unexpected
again that's to help with the um
delivery of the
ongoing services because of the pandemic
so what it means in a nutshell is that
setting the budget this year was nowhere
near as challenging as we initially
thought it was going to be because all
of the things that we thought were going
to come out such as new homes bonus
and the business rates reform and the
fair funding review didn't happen
we're now expecting all of those to
happen in the new year
um 2022 so what we've done effectively
is pushed all of those budget pressures
back a year
so what that means is we've been able to
set balance general from budget for
21.22
with a very very small um deficit of 133
000 which i'm expecting to be able to
cover off with efficiency savings and
vacancies throughout the year
so as you'll be aware council tax
increases in the past
there's been a national um
barrier on what we can actually charge
sorry for wanting clutching around for
the right word there
it's set at 1.99 or five pounds exactly
the same as in previous years
um this there's an increasing reliance
on the
on the system on the current funding
system for councils there's an
increasing reliance
on councils to collect their the money
that they need to meet the cost of their
services
from local taxation and from council tax
but that's very difficult for local
politicians
because you've got to also balance that
up against the need
and the impact on your taxpayers so this
year
um members are proposing to counsel an
increase of 1.95
just moving on to um the hra there's no
real major budget pressures within
the hra this year the the hra's been
relatively insulated from from covid and
has not
suffered the upsets that the general
funds suffered so far so we've not
really got any budget
pressures identified in the hra um
rents are being increased by 1.5 percent
this year which is in line with rent
guidance
and then they will be reviewed annually
there on in we're not taking the
decision to review rents
um for future years it's just this year
that
that cabinet are going to recommend
council a 1.5 percent increase
we've engaged with nord homes over their
management fee and they've agreed that
they will cash limit their management
fee in the same way that the general
fund budgets are cash limited
and so a fee of 9.692 million has been
approved
proposed for approval and in terms of
the capital program which should be able
to see at appendix 4
for the general fund the highlights in
there are that there's
refurbishment costs for killer marsh
leisure center and the vehicle
replacement program increases from 2022.
the vehicle replacement program you'll
be aware does fluctuate depending on
what we have to replace we don't just
replace the vehicles because the program
says so
we try and push them out as long as we
can and make them last as long as we can
so that will probably decrease again in
future years
and in terms of the hra and this is this
is exactly what what
stephen and paul was saying from all in
close earlier is we've taken the
decision this year to
pull forward seven million pounds to do
some additional
eco works on the non-trad properties
you'll all be aware that we've got a
high proportion of non-trad
properties within our stock and an
opportunity has arisen to be able to
drill down some grant funding to be able
to do a lot more work on those
properties
so we were planning to do this in future
years anyway what we've decided to do is
pull that money forward because we can
leave her in some grant funding i think
we can draw down about a million pound
which is
which is really really good news um and
i'm happy to take any questions i won't
go through the detail because i know you
all will and i'll have lots of questions
for me so i'm happy to
to move to the questions at that point
any questions
council barca
thank you uh again it's it's i don't
think we've got many options to be
honest i'm not gonna make any uh
grandstanding or anything like that just
just again for my benefit jane on page
six
or page 105 i think is better uh
on the reserves and it mentions how much
we've got a working balance of 2 million
and
investor saver 2.7 and then on
on the next bullet point 1.27
uh that we've took some money one point
well 1.2 million there to resilient
reserves
that's first time i've had that
resilience reserve
how many reserves have we got we've got
we've got quite a lot we've got quite a
lot of reserves but you're absolutely
right the resilience reserve is a new
one that we established last year
completely fortuitously it was
established to deal with the
potential shortfalls in new homes bonus
that we expected
and business rates so so we decided that
instead of just having the investor save
pot which was all about reinvesting
spending to make another pound
we also maybe needed something to
protect against losses
and so the resilience reserve was
created last year to protect against
those very losses
um as it's happened what we've used it
for in actual fact
is to to put the kovid money in there
the kobe grants that we've been
receiving from the government
so what i've been doing is i've been
putting the kodi grants into the
resilience reserve
and then i'm going to be paying out of
the resilience reserve to protect
against the costs or the incomes more
specifically particularly leisure
um to protect those services against the
losses that they're facing because of
covid
so i probably ought to call it the
resilience reserve brackets covered this
year because that's pretty much what it
is
okay it would just i suppose i would
have been a bit too
sarcastic but it's it's what what we
used to call it
the back pocket one that that we we
never sent to know about
you said just magic all of a sudden a
little money appears
uh but generally uh
all right with this we okay this year
but if you look at the overriding
thing uh going forward
24-25 two and a half million pounds
we're not in a good place particularly
let's be honest
where we are it is what it is as they
say
council shipment i will talk about the
elephants in the room
but given how dire it looks
why are we looking at killer marsh
sports center
okay this is the difference that is the
elephant in their own ross i didn't i
didn't like it
into the room it's killer martial center
okay i'm just going to talk about this
from a fire management perspective
because that that was a political
decision taken by cabinet so
i i just you know advised cabinet on the
financial position and then cabinet make
a decision
in terms of in terms of the mtfp for the
first three years
it doesn't hit the mtfp that
significantly because of the um
cushion the the i can't remember what
they've called it they've used some
fancy name for it but
the subs today that killer marsh parish
council are going to
give the council council club needs to
declare an interest
yes i might need to leave the room
councillor club you may just need to
yes that's a very good point chair um
and just a reminder to members that
we're actually in open session currently
yeah yeah sorry i wasn't i wasn't here
at the start
yeah i do need to declare an interest in
this now we're discussing kill marsh
uh and happy to leave the room at this
moment what's the legalities nikki
on this i've just just thought on that
is the illegal
aspect we were confidential uh yeah so
this is the confidential item that you
discussed
um at the the last meeting of council so
obviously the conversations that
took place therein are still
confidential
yeah it is worth pointing out that the
district council have announced that
they are investing this morning
or this i think before we go any further
i think counterclock does need to be put
in a room
so could you do that first yeah are you
are you happy for me to do that for you
council club to withdraw you
thank you council club and uh your
discretion if you do feel that the
conversation is starting to move in
uh um
if we start to move into perhaps areas
we shouldn't
then then we'll stop it there but let's
have the conversation see where we go
so back to you jane yes we're talking
about the finances which which
which is in the mtfp report which will
be a public report that goes to council
for you all to decide on so
in terms of the finances i i think i'll
take nicky's advice but i think we're
okay to continue at this
at this stage so within the mtfp the
parish council are subsidizing the
district council for the first three
years to the some
to the to songs that were described in
the previous report i'm not going to
identify those because they may be
subject to the privacy of the previous
report but
it does mean that the burden on the
general fund for the first
few years is is minimal
going on longer term it does become more
of a burden to us but that's when our
leisure services team are hopeful that
they would have been able to
improve the facility and improve the
income generation so that that won't be
such a burden
but that's why arrangements have been
having to trade very carefully here
arrangements will be put in place to to
protect both organizations
i'd probably not rather go further no i
think that's a concession
pathway very nicely um it is public
knowledge and one way because an
announcement has been made
so so i think the public are aware
could debate and we could discuss and we
could agree or whatever but from an
audit point of view
we're looking at the financial side of
it
and the decision-making process and
where we go from here
because i think the audit committee also
has a role to play in scrutinizing the
finances of it going forward
and i think we should but not just the
killer marsh one
all leisure centers as well
so i think we can agree that that's uh
on our forward plan for the audit
committee council shipment
chair will we be um seeing the contents
of the arrangement once it's been done
so we can scrutinize it before it goes
to council
yeah nikki um can i just clarify what
council ship business asking for
well presumably there's gonna be an
arrangement that's gonna be drawn up at
some point
about the how that the whole
arrangement's gonna be governed
who's gonna be paying what and and you
know i
i think it's probably our role to see
that
before it's just science hill delivered
and we've not had time to scrutinize it
um you may want to make a resolution
then that you're requesting pre-scrutiny
of that item
of business can we do that here full
council
um you can do that as i believe that
should be uh jane or correct me that
should be within the remit of this
committee if you'd like to
request um pre-scrutiny it can also go
through to the scrutiny officer
obviously he's not in attendance
currently
um and she could always reallocate that
to a different scrutiny committee if
appropriate
jane yeah that sounds right to me nikki
yeah in that case can i
can i you found yourself a seconder
already
so so it's been proposed by council
shipment then and seconded by councillor
barker
um that we do have i won't really say no
i will second it but i would just bring
man up just to clarify
all right that is is it right for it to
come to this committee or
or in other security committees what are
you advising if we because it i think
it's just about the uh
the management arrangements or what well
it's not
so much the financial uh
bit because that's been decided it's
it's how
what what do you call it i think that's
a good question i think
i think we're all sort of in principle
understanding that pre-scrutiny would be
well yes it's which scrutiny it goes
before
if it's financial the financial case
that's one thing for this committee but
the actual delivery of it
and the management of the the center so
to speak
might be best in another committee yeah
i'm definitely talking about the
financial arrangement okay and the deal
that's been agreed
yeah yeah yeah i'm happy to say that
then that we have a pre-scrutiny i don't
know how we
deal with that nikki but al seconded
what ross has just said
i think nikki
so we can build that into the forward
plans for this meeting and also
uh build that into the time scales where
it's going to go through to
um other bodies such as cabinet or
council um
just to make sure that we build in that
time scale i would have thought if
you're looking at the governance and
finance arrangements that would sit
within the remit of this committee
um if for any reason it burst onto the
leisure services aspect of that
that would sit under communities and
then perhaps we need the cabinet member
responsible and the officer responsible
for that decision-making to uh
outline the decision-making process for
the committee
okay so the team have noted that today
and that'll that'll appear in your
minutes
um and also i've noted that to make sure
that that's planned incorrectly
is the committee agreeing it's been
proposing seconded do we have an
alternative
or are we all happy with that all in
favor
yeah that's uh that's kerry unanimously
thank you
can we not talk about killer mosh now
and re-admit
councillor club uh yes chair i'll just
get him back in okay
thank you
welcome back
thank you for your patience yeah thank
you
um anything else on the report
my mind was only a small one about 1.48
which is about the um
at 1.49 sorry about parking solutions
we'd set aside 288 000
per annum so to come to that uh figure
which seemed a bit random
we we must have an outline of the car
parking solutions
and where they're going to be i believe
there is chair and that's with our
colleagues at ricknord homes so i'll
i'll confer with them and ask them to um
speak to you about that yeah thank you
because it would be nice to know where
because
i know i did see an outline one then
nothing ever materialized
i'm sure all ward members would like to
know where they are
where starting and who's next and so on
i've missed i've missed that one martin
i don't well thank you
no i shall accept your apology in
writing
thank you um and i also welcome the fact
that this report
has come to us before cabinet on the
28th of january
thank you um that's really good so can
we move to recommendation 6.1 do we have
a proposal please
thank you council armitage to have a
second day council shipment thank you
all in favor
thank you that's carried so much item
seven forward plan
anything that you want to say jane on
the forward plan i think we've already
added some things of our own
no thank you chair i think between me
nikki and damon we'll add the items that
you've
you've raised and we'll make sure that
they get on for next time i've got
nothing further to add if nicki or damon
hasn't
anything from governance not from
nietzsche
i'm sure you've got a record of
everything we've said today which has
given you a list as long as you're armed
thank you anything else anybody wants to
add to our forward plan that we haven't
mentioned today
if not move to item eight then to
consider any items which the chairs
of the opinion should be considered as a
matter of urgency i don't have any
so item nine the date and time of next
meeting is uh 10th of february
at three o'clock can i thank you very
much for your attendance and declare
the meeting closed thanks everybody
you